the high standard of living which
America has been able to attain is based
on our ability to produce goods in
quantity mass production is the basis
for our entire economic life land labor
management and money are some of the
essentials of production however if the
land is idled it cannot produce anything
of value if labor is idle it cannot
produce but this man could be a producer
if he had a job this man may have many
of the qualifications of leadership and
management so necessary for successful
business but without money he has
nothing to manage idle dollars lying in
a bank vault are not helping to put
either the land the labor or the manager
to work if a man who has ability
imagination initiative courage and
leadership is able to bring together
these essentials of production the
fields of industry may start these men
have agreed to go into partnership and
put their money and abilities to work in
building a factory to produce something
that can be sold at a profit soon the
land is in use labor is brought in to
build the factory money is in
circulation to buy materials and to pay
management and labor and later more
labor is required to operate the
machinery of production land labor
management and money have been brought
together to work effectively of the many
new businesses started only a few grow
to the extent that they may need
additional capital to build a larger
building to buy more machinery to employ
more labor this money may be obtained
through profits from the sale of the
product
or possibly from officers employees and
friends who invest their capital as part
owners of the corporation that is formed
in a few years more money may be needed
to expand plant facilities further the
manager and his associates beside they
must obtain funds outside their own
organization so they decide to summon an
investment banker to help them gather
the necessary funds the banker analyzes
the business trends investigates the
character and ability of the men in
charge and checks the financial record
of the business over a period of years
he may also send an engineer to the
plant to study its machinery building
and production capacities the banker
after consulting the engineer and the
auditor concludes that the factory can
produce more goods at a profit if money
can be gathered to expand it and that is
what the banker agrees to do to get
additional money by the sale of
securities he explains the idea to a
number of his customers who have surplus
funds for investment in productive
enterprises so far the proposition seems
financially sound what other thing we'll
start be listed on the stock exchange I
want to be assured eventually of a
market for it yes the company has agreed
to make application to list as soon as
the Richard requirements of the stock
exchange can be met all right I'll take
100 shares of ten dollars a share I'll
have a check for you tomorrow and thus
the investment banker gathers the
necessary funds from many customers each
person who invests his money is given a
receipt for the money invested this
receipt may be a bond if the corporation
merely borrows the money for a stated
period or it may be a stock certificate
if the investor becomes a part owner in
either case the investor receives
interest on his run or a dividend
the stock as the corporation prospers
expanding business means money is
circulating from wages paid to labor and
management and from dividends or
interest paid to investors it means that
stores shops and other businesses and
professions are active and prospering
after a period of successful operation
the Board of Directors decides to make
application to list its security on the
stock exchange but before this
application can be made detailed
financial statements must be compiled
and must be checked and certified by
independent Certified Public Accountants
the company agrees to do many things to
safeguard buyers and sellers steel
engraved certificates that cannot be
altered and independent registration of
ownership are just a few of the many
precautions over an extended period many
conferences with government officials
attorneys auditors and businessmen are
held before the numerous regulations of
the Securities and Exchange Commission
can be met after the corporation has met
all the requirements for listing the
manager presents the material to an
official of the Stock Exchange let's
listen to the end of their interview
I believe I have all the data you will
need you have our application with a
three-year all is prepared by approved
accountants it appears to be a very fine
report by the way how many stockholders
do you have we have 1600 stockholders at
present we want to provide them with the
advantages of an organized market where
our stockholders can sell if they choose
and others may buy with the greatest
speed and safety well I will present
your application to the Board of
Governors on Wednesday for approval of
listing and I will advise you of its
decision thank you I shall expect to
hear from you soon and I hope terribly
well aye sir goodbye and thank you Sam
and I are exam of this application and
thoughtful officials of the company
about its record and I recommend further
Malaysia the careful study of this
application I would think it a desirable
lifting there's no further discussion of
motion is now in order I move the
application be accepted I'll forgive the
most emotion is the maybe second that
all those in favor say aye I hold most
is Terry Smith you certify this to the
securities exchange commission for
registration yes sir a little runny in
addition to checking the financial
standing of the corporations whose
stocks it handles the exchange regulates
the business conduct and financial
conditions of its own members by a set
of rules and regulations all designed to
protect the investor all members must
sign an agreement to abide by all the
rules and regulations of the exchange
without question these members must
submit at least two certified financial
statements annually also the exchange
staff of auditors at least once a year
makes a careful audit and check up on
the business conduct and financial
condition of all members
the board of governors of the exchange
is empowered to act in any way necessary
to protect the public welfare in stock
exchange transactions the exchange sets
very high standards for persons who wish
to become members an applicant for
membership must prove himself to be a
man of unimpeachable character and have
a business record that is beyond
question he must have adequate financial
resources readily convertible into cash
to do the type of business he intends to
do
when the SEC registers to stock it has
admitted to trading on the exchange
floor thus serving buyers and sellers of
securities suppose the original investor
now finds himself in need of funds for
example to build a new house he knows
that the stock exchange is a marketplace
for his stock so he goes to the office
of a member of the exchange and tells
one of the brokers that he has decided
to sell his stock in American
manufacturing corporation he asks the
broker at what price the stock is listed
the broker tells him that the last sale
was at nineteen three-quarters of share
which means nineteen dollars and
seventy-five cents a share he instructs
the broker to sell his 100 shares at the
market many investors do not come to the
brokers office but make their sales and
purchases by telephone telegram or
letter after the broker has written out
the order he hands it to the order clerk
the order clerk first time stamps the
order and then telephones it to the
floor of the stock exchange on the floor
of the exchange this telephone order is
written out at a booth attended by an
employee of the exchange member this
phone is the exchange end of a private
line to the members office the floor
clerk now passes the order along to
another employee of the firm who goes to
the trading post meanwhile at another
members booth in order to buy 100 AMC at
20 may be received this order is also
related to the trading post when a
security is admitted to trading one of
these trading posts becomes the
marketplace for it here selling vocals
and buying brokers meat and trades
transactions involving thousands of
dollars are contracted for by a warning
or a nod of the head yes change recorder
on the left is portrayed on a slip of
paper and hands it to a messenger the
messenger timestamps it and hands it to
the stock ticker operator the operator
sends a record of the transaction out
over the ticker from which it becomes
known all over the country the
transaction is also recorded on this
huge blackboard so that all members and
employees of the exchange will know that
someone has sold and someone has bought
and at what price and in what volume the
floor clerk also reports the sale by
telephone to his brokerage office
meanwhile the seller who is waiting in
the brokers office watches the ticker
tape to learn the trend of the market as
soon as the broker hears about the
transaction by telephone he reports the
sale and the price to his customer if
the seller brings the stock certificates
with him the broker gives him a receipt
for his securities and advises him that
a check will be sent out in a few days
the seller may not bring the
certificates however and in this case
the transaction is completed by mail so
far the transaction has been very simple
at least for the seller and buyer but
there is much more to be done by the
broker and his staff before the
transaction is completed a written
confirmation of the transaction is
mailed to the seller by the selling
broker and also to the buyer by the
buying broker on the floor of the
exchange the selling brokers clerk makes
out an exchange ticket of the
transaction which looks like this
he deposits the ticket in the
distributing Department of the stock
Clearing Corporation each member has one
of these boxes and after the tickets are
sorted the buying brokers clerk stamps
the ticket in confirmation and
redeposited in the Clearinghouse
information on these tickets is
transferred by this card punching
machine to what is called a punch card
the cards are then sorted in an
automatic sorting machine from many of
these cards containing similar
information for various transactions the
Clearinghouse prepares a record of each
member's transactions for the day in
this automatic tabulating machine if the
selling broker has bought 100 AMC for
another customer the Clearinghouse will
eliminate delivery outside the brokers
office by merely balancing his receipts
and deliveries only the Clearinghouse
balances are delivered the final step in
a transaction is the delivery of the
check from the broker to the seller this
is usually done by mail generally this
occurs only two or three days after the
sale is made the investor receives a
check from which has been deducted the
broker's commission and the federal tax
and he is ready to put this money into
circulation again in the building of his
new home